hi I'm Heather and we're here at the
certification lounge at neck 17 and in
with Neil Neil can you tell us a little
bit about yourself
sure so I'm Neil shapour I director with
in PwC's cloud practice I'm also helping
drive the Google cloud go to market
offerings so I'm right now cloud
architect certified and I've also taken
the big data engineer exam
personally it's great that I'm a current
now with the latest technologies for p
CC our customers are just getting
started on this journey and now this is
a very very evolving cloud ecosystem and
they need somebody who has been there
before and and these certifications
helps validate our credentials and when
we can take them through this journey so
PwC VAR a Maki sponsor for Google goes
cloud but we have been a strategic
partner since 2015
and we actually internally transformed
ourselves using good G suite and then we
have maybe or thousand GCP projects also
teed up within the firm so we have gone
through this journey ourselves and now
we are helping our customers take a
similar journey